[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur konditorei
morath therese und servicewelt ja wie
ihr vielleicht schon mitbekommen habt
sind wir prädestiniert dafür dass wir
originale nachmachen und ihr habt mir
einige vorschläge geschickt das letzte
mal habe ich was habe ich gemacht vom
coppenrath herz dort habe ich gemacht
von der conditorei coppenrath & wiese
also nicht fertig torte aus dem kühlfach
hier habe ich jetzt die meister torte
bienenstich und dazu muss ich sagen das
war ein wunsch von murat aber auch von
euch denn murat liebt bienenstich und er
hat mir damals als wir uns kennengelernt
haben schon gesagt sally bitte macht den
bienenstich sowie bei coppenrath & wiese
denn hier ist es nämlich so dass eine
sahne creme innern ist und viele
konditoreien und bäckereien oder auch wo
bücher oder rezepte sind so dass einfach
eine buttercreme drin ist also mache ich
das heute so sieht die torte aus das ist
ein rührteig das steht auch auf der
rückseite rührteig bienenstich wohnen
und boden
und der ist auch relativ flach ist gar
nicht so hoch finde ich auch echt ganz
gut weil es einfach eine torte ist die
man eben mal schnell zubereiten kann
ich habe mir jetzt dafür einen hellen
sache wurden ausgesucht aus meinem
basics und ich zeige euch mal die
zutaten für den teig verwende ich sieben
eiweiß eine prise salz 120 gramm zucker
170 g weiche butter 120 gramm
puderzucker etwas vanille extrakt 750
gramm mehl und etwas lauwarmer milch und
das ist im boden dem ich einfach
abgewandelt habe von der dunklen
sachertorte das auch so ein tag aber
eben mit cacau da ich jetzt ein kv
weggelassen und macht praktisch die
helle variante der ist nämlich total
fein und ich denke da passiert ganz gut
und später kommt da eben noch dieser
wandel kruste drauf okay die torte hier
die taucht noch ein bisschen auf die
werde ich gleich wenn man natürlich auch
gleich verkosten und probieren und wie
gesagt geht es bei den nachgemacht
videos nicht darum ein original besser
zu machen günstiger zu machen schneller
oder appetitlicher sondern es geht
einfach darum zu wissen wie macht man so
eine torte nach was steckt da für arbeit
dahinter und vor allem könnt ihr die
zutaten die ihr vielleicht nicht
verträgt oder nicht mögt nicht verwenden
gold wie zum beispiel gelatine eben ganz
einfach austauschen und lang selber
deswegen machen wir das okay los geht's
also ich nehme jetzt zwei schüsseln in
der einen schlüssel schlage ich nämlich
das eiweiß und in der anderen das mache
ich jetzt hier schon mal kann ich jetzt
die butter verrühren
die ist schön weich und zimmer warm da
solltet ihr auch darauf achten dass alle
zutaten zählen sind
hier gebe ich jetzt noch den puderzucker
dazu und das waren die längsten
da kann ich die zutaten hier ist ganz
schön cremig verrühren ich schalte die
maschine gleich an und hier in der
zweiten schlüssel kann ich dann schon
mal das eiweiß steif schlagen mit salz
und da jetzt aber nicht zu lange röhren
der zucker kommt gleich dazu
das ganze sollte nicht zu trocken
gerührt werden sondern eher so schluckt
ich lass das wort und muss es begeistern
doch immer wieder benutzen diese seite
wissen wir dass die prise salz bewegt
übrigens dass die eiweiß struktur
schneider zerstört wird daher gebe ich
sie beim aufschlagen zum eiweiß immer
gerne dazu weil es eben schneller geht
jetzt einfach langsam den zucker
dazugeben
du sitzt noch ein bisschen zu flüssig
aber bis zur kurz vorm sterben so lange
sich wurden
[Musik]
die konsistenz der perfekt jetzt kann
ich hier zur weiß cremigen buttermesser
einfach die eigelbe dazugeben eins nach
dem anderen
also mal einen einrühren jetzt warten
bis sich alles rund um hard und dann das
nächste etappe zu geben
jetzt kann ich hier den eischnee im
wechsel mit dem mehl und der milch
unterheben
ich nehme erst mal ein bisschen schnee
um die butter messe ist ein bisschen
aufzulockern und ihr seht auch ich
brauche kein backpulver hier im teig das
kommt daher weil ich ja wirklich die
butter maße lange gerührt habe und für
die lockerung sorgt eben auch der schnee
also das lange röhren ist hier schon
sehr wichtig gerade bei der butter dann
das mehl dazugeben mail vhs 7 natürlich
damit keine klümpchen gibt und die milch
noch dazu geben und die sollte entweder
zimmer warm oder eben lauwarm sein damit
die butter masse nicht gerinnt
[Musik]
perfekt jetzt gar nicht so lange rühren
sondern wirklich nur kurz unternehmen
den ofen habe ich übrigens schon vor
geheißen das mache ich meist immer dann
wenn ich meine zu taten bereit habe denn
der ofen sollte im reis seien außer ich
sag ihnen wieder was anderes zb die habe
ich schon den tortenring den habe ich
auf 26 cm durchmesser eingestellt kann
die masse jetzt einfüllen und jetzt hier
einfach vorsichtig verteilen
ich glaube die masse wird auch gereicht
mit 5 1
aber ich will es jetzt auch nicht zu
flach haben jetzt guck ich einfach mal
und normalerweise mag ist bei
bienenstich so dass ich direkt auch
schon die mandel masse darauf gebe aber
ich versuche es jetzt mal so ich möchte
jetzt erstmal vor backen denn ich will
auch diese schöne gleichmäßige schicht
haben also das packe ich jetzt hier und
kann gleich dann die mandel massen zu
bereiten die muss nämlich auf herthas
mal erwärmt werden
[Musik]
dafür verwende ich einfach 50 gramm
sahne 50 gramm zucker 100 gramm
gehobelte mandeln und etwas vanille
extrakt ich gebe jetzt einfach die sahne
in einen topf der zucker kommt dazu und
dann lasse ich jetzt die zutaten hier
kurz aufkochen
so löst sich der zucker schön auf und
dann haben wir später eine schöne kruste
ich finde es gerade so krass dass sahne
wenn sie mit zucker gekocht wird so
transparent wird wieso kondensmilch aber
wir spielen eben gesagt grüne konsens
sieht echt grün aus komisch nur ganz
kurz kochen jetzt gebe ich direkt schon
den mandeln dazu und es darf jetzt auch
hier schon gerne ein bisschen farbe
bekommen
vanille extrakt darf auch nicht fehlen
ich weiß nicht ob ihr wandel extrakt
benutzt habt wandel habe ich es nicht
gesehen in den zutaten aber es wäre
keine seele torte ben saly nicht vanille
benutzen würde
das hier ist jetzt nur ganz leicht farbe
jetzt schalte ich den herd aus und warte
einfach nur noch auf den kuchen im
backofen denn dann kommt diese schicht
direkt auf den kuchen und wird noch mal
mit gebacken und ich habs jetzt nicht
sofort mit gebacken und vielleicht noch
kurz zur erklärung normalerweise mache
ich das beim beben stich aber ich möchte
jetzt auch nicht dass die mandeln hinein
sinken in den teig also wirklich schön
als kruste oben drauf bleiben so wie
eben bei dem kuchen hier
und deswegen probiert's diesmal einfach
so vor backen und daneben obendrauf
geben
der kuchen weiß bereits nach 25 minuten
schon gut dass ich habe eine stäbchen
probe gemacht da bleibt nichts mehr
hängen
jetzt kommt hier dem maße drauf die
müsste auch einfach kurz vor ende zu
bereiten damit sie eben nicht abkühlt
und dazu kann nicht fest wird
ich sehe einfach nur mal kurz erwärmt
und jetzt hier gleichmäßig darauf geben
und verstreichen und dann noch mal in
den backofen geben
[Musik]
die menge reicht es nicht ganz aus ich
mache noch mal die gleiche menge und
gibt es hier drauf das heißt einfach vom
belag die doppelte menge benutzen
[Musik]
ich hab's mir fallen kurz gedacht aber
ich dachte ich probiere es machen
ich mache es auch sturm waffel und koch
hierbei power boost ich habe gelernt
dass gehört geht dann alles schneller
man macht es mit
konkurrent der topfboden aber nicht aber
aufgepasst jetzt die master hier drauf
schön verteilen
am besten wirklich ganz frisch machen
und dann ab in den backofen damit die
schicht noch schön karamellisierte
[Musik]
die studie muss er darin extrem
stromverbrauch haben ja immer bei power
boost schon nicht ohne sorgen jetzt
kommt der kuchen wieder in den backofen
damit die obere schicht karamellisieren
kann und dann nichts mittlere einen
schub freuen was darunter jetzt habe ich
den mittleren ich habe mir die schicht
schönen karamellisieren kann jetzt mit
kamera zurück da hätte ich die nicht
treffen denn die kamera kennt stände ich
mal wenn man jetzt am kochfeld schon den
sturm ihr gemacht haben machen wir das
jetzt auch am backofen
ich habe jetzt nämlich nach 5 minuten
bei 180° noch keine werbung gesehen aber
ich will jetzt auch nicht zu lange
backen damit der kunde nicht trocken
wird also habe ich jetzt auf grill
gestellt und
jetzt tut sich was ich muss jetzt nur
nebendran stehen bleiben
[Musik]
der bienenstich großen rätsel der
bienenstich boden ist jetzt abhaken und
jetzt machen wir die creme den kuchen
habe ich jetzt einfach kurz im
kühlschrank gestellt und wir brauchen
sie dafür sahne butter zucker vanille
extrakt und seiner party zu steif
schlagen kann ich erst mal ein liter
genommen denn ich muss jetzt erst mal
gucken wie viel ich brauche was kann und
puderzucker aber nicht alles da müssen
wir erst mal nach geschmack gucken also
ruhig erstmal nur so ein bisschen gucken
wir ausschließen und bisschen extra
hatte mal wir machen jetzt erstmal den
hocker richtig geht man wieder hier nach
links so ist besser bisschen warten
länder noch nicht das mache ich dann
rein ok und du darfst rühren rühren will
und dann kommt so ein paar 13 steif
schlagen
gut festhalten hatte ich halt bisschen
mit ok da ist die vanilleschote trinker
und sie wird zerkleinert
das sind das ist dass vanille meisters
der vanilleschote wird es so ausgeklappt
kann so und mal zwei löffel holen und
können wir die sahne probieren ob die
noch zucker drin ist der große für mich
wachstumsprobleme kurze wege noch zucker
drin haben ich bin das ist genug
getreide oder vielmehr einstecken denn
wenn die küchenmaschine übertraf man das
nicht machen ist es ganz gefährlich weil
dann klappt der löffel drin stecken und
dann ist richtig gefährlich wenn die
maschine rollt die auch nicht haben uns
schnell mal wenn die maschine läuft beim
haare weg und finger weg okay
[Musik]
hier ist jetzt der kuchen boden den
lösen ist raus buck folie könnte immer
so drunter weg gewonnen und stand mit
einem back vom land lösen könnte
entweder den deckel mit orten säge
herunter schneiden oder mit einem messer
ich nehme jetzt das kuchen messer und
nehme einfach die dreh platte denn dann
könnt ihr das messer hier am rand
ansetzen und die tortenplatte drehen und
dann einmal durch
und jetzt will ich ganz kurz die sahne
creme in den spritzbeutel mit einer
großen loch hülle ein
denn ich möchte ja auch wie hier diese
tupfen am rand haben
und normalerweise mache ich es bei
bienenstich immer so dass ich jetzt den
deckel nehme und schon mal zwölf top
stücke zu schneiden und dann eben erst
auf die sahne setzte denn ein
bienenstich ist einfach so diese
knusprige schicht da oben
da kommt man besser nicht so leicht
durch das heißt wenn man dann die torte
anschneiden drückt man die sahne
bisschen zusammen
aber ich möchte jetzt original trifft
sie machen also mache ich jetzt auch
regional wie hier
ich werde also den deckel im ganzen
lassen ich hoffe ich bereue es später
nicht aber ich werde es später
vielleicht einfach vor dem anschneiden
ein bisschen einfrieren
das hilft die original torte eben auch
die sollen ja auch im gefrorenen zustand
noch zu schneiden
also komm einfach beide gleich ins
gefrierfach
[Musik]
und die spritz zähle die lege ich immer
so in den sprit bodenständer hier einmal
umknicken so quillt keine sau raus und
dann den schritt vor die öffnen
fertig und so hat er jetzt einfach die
hand frei und könnte den beutel gut
gefüllt
ich bin eigentlich kein fan von nur
sahne creme also ich mache eigentlich
gerne so eine quark sahne oder
frischkäse sahne
aber wir wollen jetzt auch regional war
jetzt kommen hier außen tupfen drauf
[Musik]
und die restliche creme kommt jetzt hier
einfach ins innere
also schön ausfüllen
[Musik]
ok bisschen weniger sein erreicht auch
ich schreibe ich natürlich dann immer
das verbesserte rezept in den block
[Musik]
hier ganz ganz glatt streichen
du hast gut gut und dann in der hoffnung
dass ich nicht bereue
kommt jetzt der komplette deckel drauf
fertig ist der bienenstich und ich
stelle ihn jetzt wir gucken erst mal
hier original vergleich ich stelle ihn
jetzt wie gesagt in den gefrierschrank
dass die sahne ein bisschen anfriert und
ich dann eben die stückchen schön
herausschneiden kann ja und dann wird
gleich verkostet
[Musik]
ich würde sagen ich schneide zumal beide
an wie gesagt beide sind noch so
innerhalb gefrorenen zustand dann geht's
eigentlich aber trotzdem wenn ihr sie
nach macht ich werde euch empfehlen den
deckel vorher durchzuschneiden
und dann lasse ich sie ganz kurz stehen
bis ein bisschen auftaut und dann darf
der moret probieren sie doch schön aus
also ich finde den schöneren glanz aber
wir lassen einfach morath gleich
problemen lieber murats com und probiere
so hat der riese stellt vor die
geschichte ja und königsallee macht
jetzt eine blindverkostung aber ich weiß
hat doch damals zu mir gesagt ich mache
mir zuerst sehr willig also ich finde es
wirklich nicht aber ich sage auch die
wahrheit
wie schmeckt city ist gut gestartet
täglich dem was ich jetzt raus dann
abgerissen ist ich bin zwar blind aber
nicht doof ok nun darf
okay auch auf ein kleiner unfall
passiert beim zusammendrücken also sag
jetzt die wahrheit so oft salz die
wahrheit ich habe gebe ich hab' ich
musste werden welche die kunden raten
diese deutlich warum machen den der
temperatur weil die wahl schon gehabt
die war ziemlich kühl noch daher habe es
gebe dass die kuppen raten wie sich ja
meine die stand jetzt für die fotos
draußen oder deswegen ist jetzt auch die
dame zu weichen temperatur also
temperatur ja gemerkt
also ging es mal voll in die hose aber
ich sage etwas ehrliches der speck wie
viel man liga wirklich ohne spaß ja also
die kommen die kuppen raten wie sie
schmecken nicht so schmeckt gut aber
nicht so gut wie murat der riese und das
mit messer wie die man lieber nicht süß
muss ich ehrlich sagen dein wissen zu
produziert also
aber wie sie zerlegt gesagt hat das
problem ist dass sie länger kühl nur
weil der stand jetzt für die fotos fast
45 minuten ohne kühlung
deswegen ist es auch jetzt aber sehr
lecker ich denke dass die in der
industrie auch mehr zucker benutze ich
meine zucker schon natürliches
konservierungsmittel alles länger
haltbar aus und ich denke auch der
geschmack der meisten ist er das so
gesagt hat ich finde eine cola und
trotzdem nicht schlecht sagt keine
unmenschen wenn ihr das kauft jetzt muss
ich noch ganz gut was sagen ich bin ja
auch wichtig ja viele denken immer sagt
drin ist schweinische latin ist aber
nichts von dem vorschlag wirklich kein
sport trotzdem schade weil ich finde er
hat bei einer sahnetorte finde ich muss
man keine gelatine immer benutzen also
da gibt es mittlerweile einfach
pflanzliche alternativen bei so einer
muss verstehe ich es noch weil einfach
bei der musikshow natürlich die textur
anders macht als acker zum beispiel eine
schwere torte oder einsperren
das ist liebe kinder der unterschied
sally ist äpfel morath ist tot mary war
also falls ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt schaut auf meiner auf mein block
vorbei ihnen vorbei da steht es noch mal
ganz genau
postet eure fotos und wie gesagt ich
finde immer besser beim bienenstich die
stücke vorher anzuschneiden weil sich
ansonsten die sahne etwas durchdrücken
kann
viel spaß beim nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal ist die schön aussehen
ich finde auch das ist so eine sonntags
torte richtig gut geld dass ich perfekt
und wenn man sie das ist richtig schön
gelb weil ich einfach bio freilandeier
nehmen und das eigelb einfach super gerd
wobei oftmals auch die narren zu tun
hätte dann anders gefüttert
[Musik]